I'm inspector Kildare of Scotland Yard
I'm investigating a series of deaths
they're calling from the Limehouse goal
of murders at Ratliff highway he
slaughtered a household the previous
week a prostitute and the golems of
madmen even madness as its own logic
inspector cook there I may have found an
eyewitness inline out sir I can't tell
you what I know just assist me I
promised I would let you think I don't
tell you
[Music]
who was here on September the 24th there
were four men that day joining cream dad
Lena George Gissing Karl Marx the
newspaper said it was your first murder
case
the yard is setting me up as a scapegoat
the public want blood The Golem provides
her
he who observes spells no less blood
than he who inflicts the blow it's a
message to us how many more people have
to die before the Golem is caught
and keep my secret and I'll keep yours
the golem is still at large wasting my
time could cost lives
I believe the golem is after me our
shelf stoppers are guaranteed
we all wear ant at my mom's doing
[Music]
what's your name
Leticia Lambeth marsh Lizzie I thought I
could smell Marsh glasses oh don't lend
damn you it's just that way and call me
Dan this is Tommy far see a manager and
keep up the bands
speaking of which we owe you something
for your trouble God's name they had you
doing down there in those marshes
digging graves five years it was before
I found out you were see to shovel I
like this one
you